this program is being presented to you
by the hereas international winter
school on gravity and light
foreign
my
this is what we'll hear when we begin to
listen
to the universe
and this is what our galaxy will
actually sound like
and it would sound like today if we
could only listen to it
this cacophony of sound is what we
expect from the most
extreme objects in the universe there
are
black holes neutron stars cosmic strings
and many many more things
all shouting for our attention
at present we're deaf
with our modern telescopes we can see
how beautiful our universe is
but there's another dimension a
different sense
which we'll soon be able to use
so as you heard i'm bernard schutz and i
was for many years
director of the max planck institute for
gravitational physics
also known as the albert einstein
institute i'm now a professor at cardiff
university in wales
the albert einstein institute in potsdam
near berlin germany
is very close to where einstein
developed his theory of general
relativity
this evening i'm going to be your guide
to something you may never have expected
to be able to do
which is to listen to a cosmic sound
made by far away objects
in our universe of course
there's no air in between stars that
carries this cosmic
sound we call it gravitational waves
there's small disturbances in the
gravitational field that moves through
the universe
at the speed of light the anything that
changes gravity
causes waves to ripple outwards
in the same way that ordinary sound is
produced when air is disturbed
gravitational waves are produced when
gravity is disturbed
we want to listen to these waves because
they contain information
about parts of the universe that we
don't see about things in the universe
that don't
shine at night now here's an analogy
imagine that we're standing in a jungle
with our earplugs in
we see the palms the exotic plants we
see
a waterfall but we don't hear anything
now the same again but with the plugs
out so we can hear sound
we quickly learn much more about the
jungle including its birds
apes which were completely hidden before
and we might even hear something
unexpected
our universe is like a jungle it's
filled with wild animals
we can't see all of them often we only
know they're there
because we can listen to the sounds that
they make the wild animals of our junk
universe are the true stars of this film
the cast includes ferociously exploding
stars called supernovas
like nuclear explosions on on the earth
they convert
some of their mass into energy blowing
themselves apart
but leaving behind a black hole or a
neutron star
and some of that energy comes out in a
short pop
of gravitational waves
and we have lonely spinning neutron
stars
cinders of a long ago supernova we call
them pulsars
because they are radio beams turning
like lighthouse beacons giving us a
radio
pulse every time they sweep across us
spinning up to a fantastic 700 times a
second
they go on like this for millions of
millions of years emissaring
emitting a whispering pure tone of
gravitational
waves at hundreds or even thousands of
cycles per second
and there are different kinds of pairs
of stars two ancient white dwarf
binary stars orbiting one another once
an hour let's say
staying at such a safe distance from
each other that they'll continuing
orbit they'll continue their orbits for
billions of years
like pulsars they emit pure tone
whispers
of gravitational waves but if they're
much lower orbital frequencies
two neutron stars orbiting one another
so closely that they merge
together even as we listen to them they
explode emitting a blinding burst of
gamma rays
they convert even more their mass into a
powerful scream
of gravitational wave energy than they
do into gamma rays
they leave behind a single quiet black
hole
the biggest stars of our film are black
holes
their merger emits no light only pure
gravitational wave energy in their death
spiral
they radiate more they radiate energy
more brightly than the entire rest of
the universe
now black holes come in at least two
sizes
there are big black holes and there are
giant black holes
big black holes are formed in supernova
explosions
and they can have 10 times as much mass
as our sun
giant black holes are formed in the
centers of galaxies
and they can have millions to billions
of sun masses
the giant holes are truly the elephants
in this jungle
and really fascinating are the mixed
couples sometimes a neutron star pairs
up with a big black hole
and sometimes a big black hole pairs up
with a giant one
the giant one eventually eats the other
one whole
later i'll play for you the piercing
scream
that we expect to hear just before
the big black hole disappears inside the
giant one
that these beasts these stars of the
jungle are all dead
objects but they're also nature's most
extreme
objects black holes for examples are
pure gravity
wrapped up into a bowl that keeps
growing listen to physicist kip thorne
who created the recent hollywood movie
interstellar
if you go down near the edge of a black
hole
time flows more slowly there enormously
more slowly than here on earth
a few minutes of time down there if you
were there
could be a million years back on earth
so what would happen if i would fall
into a black hole would i end up
somewhere else in another universe you'd
die
i'd die inside a black hole there's
something we call a singularity
singularity is a place where we don't
understand what's going on
but we do know that gravity becomes so
strong there
that it rips you apart
it will rip the atoms that your body is
made from apart
it destroys matter it destroys all forms
of matter and even destroys space and
time right at the center
if you fall into a black hole you die
happily people don't usually fall into
black holes
but stars do the last chance a
collapsing star has to avoid this fate
is to form a neutron star
neutron stars are the densest objects we
know
inside a neutron star
the temperature can be millions of
degrees
but it will still be a superconductor
and a superfluid
some physicists speculate that matter is
in a different state inside neutron
stars technically not a strange matter
these gravitational wave emitters that
we've seen
these are the growlers and howlers of
our universe
they're places of extreme physics
we know of many such individuals already
but many others out there are hidden
will only discover and study them
by listening to their gravitational
waves
but almost certainly there are unknown
beasts that we don't yet
expect to hear even some may be
associated
not with dead stars but with birth the
birth
of our universe physicists want to find
relics left over from the big bang and
we want to listen
to the gravitational waves emitted by
the big bang
so what are gravitational waves
so gravitational waves are waves in
space they're waves of space
the medium really is space itself
space is full of waves from exploding
stars
merging stars spinning stars
and of course black holes
now our computers can calculate
what waves we should expect
with gravitational waves we'll finally
fully be able to observe the universe to
listen for things
hidden in the most remote corners and
behind the thickest screams
and eventually even back to the big bang
now remember gravitational waves are not
sound waves as we normally understand
them
because there's no air between the stars
to carry those
sound but space itself carries the
gravitational disturbances to our
detectors
and our computers can convert these
disturbances into the sounds that we
listen to
we've already heard one of these
this is the true music of the spheres
now warning gravitational waves are not
really as loud as that
in fact they're the weakest and quietest
waves science has ever tried to detect
we need very special ears to pick them
up gravitational wave detectors
they are in principle ultra sensitive
microphones for gravitational
waves there are five big detector
projects around the world
and they all work together
the two giant american ligo
observatories in the states of louisiana
and washington
virgo another giant detector near pisa
italy which is a cooperation among italy
france and the netherlands
the kagura detector in japan
the ligo india project
and geo 600 the german british project
near hanover germany
dio is operated by the albert einstein
institute
in germany
geo is a kind of think tank from here
come key technologies that are
transferred to the larger observatories
at many universities around the world
big supercomputers process the data
the biggest and fastest of them all is
the atlas cluster at the albert einstein
institute
the first gravitational waves will be
heard here
the first system we detect will probably
be a couple of tumbling and colliding
neutron stars
in reality they'll orbit each other much
faster than
shown here and we expect to match them
up with a spectacular gamma-ray burst
that they create here's that was what we
expected to hear
that little plop it was only the part of
the signal audible to our ears
our computers will pick out in our data
the much lower pitched whistle before it
and we'll be able to identify it as a
pair of neutron stars
we'll also be listening for the
continuous whale of a rapidly spinning
neutron star
what we call a pulsar these waves
are emitted when a misshapen neutron
star spins
the bumps on it keep changing gravity as
the star turns
and the moving bumps create the
gravitational waves
once we've made these first detections
we need to do
better we will need to be able to make
routine detections to explore the
gravitational wave universe
in a study funded by the european union
scientists have shown what the next
stage must be
we have to go underground the einstein
telescope
would hear these gravitational wave
sounds out to the edge of the known
universe
to do that it needs to be bigger have
more powerful
lasers but above all be quieter
on earth quiet means deep maybe 200
meters deep
and inside 10 kilometer long tunnels
that of course will be the future today
we're preparing the existing detectors
all over the world
to make the first ever detections
now i want to show you why we need
detectors
all over the world
okay i'm stopping the film and uh uh
we're going to have two
demonstrations during the course of this
film and i'll be
assisted in this by my two assistants
claudia
leon who are going to now um
explain to you why we're going to do a
demonstration for you the three of us
together we're going to do a
demonstration to you
to you about why we have placed
gravitational wave detectors all over
the world
instead of just having a single detector
and the reason for that
is we want to be able to tell where
gravitational wave sound
gravitational wave has come from um
so uh we
are going to be three different black
hole binary systems
and you are going to be the
gravitational wave detectors
uh now what we're going to do is we're
going to
make the sound of two black of two black
holes crashing together you'll have to
use your imagination to
uh accept that that's what we're doing
uh
and then um uh you're go i'm gonna ask
you to try to remember where that sound
came from so for this demonstration
i'd ask you to close i'll i will ask you
in a moment to close your eyes
and keep your eyes closed uh as we move
around
and and you uh listen to the sounds so
each time
these black holes crash together i want
you to remember only one simple thing
um uh where did that sound come from
and uh in uh could you tell the
difference from
from one one of these black hole systems
to the to the other
as to where they came from and then
after that's all finished we're all
going to come together again then i will
ask you to open your eyes
and we'll take we'll talk about the
result we'll take a vote we'll see
see what uh you're able to do okay so
please
everyone close your eyes and don't open
them again until i
ask you um and now
we're going to make three different uh
black hole collisions and um
the uh number one will be liam
number two is claudia now keep your eyes
closed
and i'm the number three
now if you can remember the that where
you thought those
sounds were coming from we're going to
change our positions a little bit
and again
um okay
uh and then again number one
number two and number three so those are
the three
black hole uh events okay
now can you you can open your eyes now
please
oh thanks and um i would uh
just like to ask uh
how many how many people felt during the
first three
that all all of these were in different
locations
right okay you have good ears because
they were uh
liam would you want to show us where you
were standing for the first one and
claudia so this is these were the
positions we were in
okay and um now
for the second demonstration again how
many people felt
we were in distinct positions
and how many felt we were uh
that there may maybe two of them were
happening in the same place
yeah okay could you show us where you
were
so they were slightly apart but they
were close enough that
particularly if you were far away you
wouldn't have been able to tell the
difference
now that's a very simple thing that we
experience all the time with our ears
but it's exactly the same thing that
happens with our gravitational wave
detectors when we detect gravitational
waves
the ears are using information like the
arrival time
of of the gravitational wave uh sorry of
the sound
uh i wish we could detect gravitational
waves with our ears
but uh arise with uh what time does the
sound arrive at one ear and
uh and the other and the and and the
nervous system is trying to work out
those small time differences it's also
trying to work out intensity differences
and so on and all those things are part
of the data that comes out of
the gravitational wave detectors as well
in order to locate on the sky
and and you probably realize that uh
this all depends upon the wavelength of
the sound
um that uh that uh and how far away you
are and how
and what the distance is between your
ears and so on how
big a distance you can resolve and so in
this case they were not
resolvable if you were if you're far
enough away
um if you're close then the angle is
better and
and so you could tell so um the same
thing is true of our gravitational wave
detectors we have rather crude positions
on this guy
because our detectors are not separated
by very much just the size of the earth
and the size of the gravitational
wavelength is really quite long
so that's uh that's the
demonstration that explains anyway why
we take great care the position
detectors
multiple detectors all working together
in different places so we have two in
the united states
one in europe one in india being built
one in
japan being built so thank you very much
for the demonstration
and we'll have another one uh later on
um
which
my the my able assistants will also help
me with so thank you very much
um so
okay so now i can restart the film
so
there's more gravitational wave
astronomy than just the gravitational
wave sounds that we'll be able to detect
with the detectors that were building on
the earth as you saw in that film
earlier
we'd also listen to to the universe in a
lower frequency range
it's a bit like astronomers who want to
have a view of the entire universe in
different wavelengths like
x-rays here if you
look at the whole sky the same universe
in optical you get a very different view
of it
and again if you make a map of the same
universe
the entire sky in radio it looks very
different
it's the same in gravitational waves
gravitational waves come in different
wavelengths
and for each wavelength we need a
different kind of detector
the interesting gravitational
wavelengths are much longer than those
of light or radio waves in fact
uh our detectors on the ground
are looking for wavelengths that are
only a little bit bigger than the earth
so that's why we have trouble resolving
their distances
their positions we need to put a
detector in orbit around the sun
if we want to look for waves which are
the scale of the solar system
and if we want to look for really long
wavelengths comparable to the
separations between
stars we need to use the stars
themselves the neutron stars that we
call
pulsars the pulses of radiate of radio
waves emitted by these neutron stars can
help us to measure gravitational waves
because some pulsars are very very good
clocks
their pulses arrive at earth with such
precise regularity
that by monitoring several pulsars at
once
we can look for gravitational waves
passing the earth as the
waves stretch and distort space they
change the distance that the pulses have
to travel
to reach us so some pulses are delayed
relative to others
and that allows us to detect the
gravitational waves that produce those
delays we call this pulsar timing
it can detect waves with ultra long
wavelengths several light years in
length
that are emitted when two of the giant
black holes
that we talked about earlier with
billions of sun masses orbit each other
very closely by about 2020
radio observatories in europe the usa
and australia
may find these slow tiny arrival time
variations
below a millisecond that are the
telltale signature of gravitational
waves from the biggest black hole
but we'll soon be begin detecting the
earth sides
and the light year size gravitational
waves which would be the major
milestones for physics
and astronomy but the richest harvest of
all will come when we can look for in
between
sizes the solar system size
gravitational waves
we'd love to do that with detectors on
the ground but we've already built
that we've already built but we have
lots of problems on the ground
and one of them is weather
our detectives are ultra sensitive to
changes of gravity
no matter how they arise and weather can
change gravity i'm not talking about
lightning or thunder
but about atmospheric pressure and
temperature changes
these can change the density of the air
that's above the detector
and as they change as they pass over the
detector they change gravity
by more than the gravity changes from
gravitational waves
from distant black holes
so to measure our long gravitational
waves we have to get away from the earth
we will also be able to measure
gravitational waves in space
the european-led lisa mission will
listen deeper into the universe
and farther back in time than ever
before
by going out into empty space lisa can
be made much bigger than the earth-based
detectors
this allows lisa to pick up waves of
much longer wavelength
which are emitted by much larger objects
such as giant black holes orbiting one
another
in order to make such sensitive
observations the lisa spacecraft will
create inside themselves
the quietest places in the solar system
only if we exclude all local
disturbances can we record the sounds
made by distant beasts
with three ultra quiet spacecraft in a
triangle a million kilometers on a site
communicating among themselves with
lasers lisa becomes the most
sensitive detector ever built
lisa will hear a cacophony of sounds
from all over the universe
from white dwarf stars in our milky way
to the roaring elephants of the giant
black hole systems far away
and far back in time lisa might even
record the earliest black holes
or even the big bang
even the mysterious dark energy might
leave its mark
in lisa's observations and
lisa's gravity measuring technology is
going to be used to study the earth
too
the grace follow-on mission uses
technology developed for lisa to measure
the small irregularities in the earth's
gravity
with unprecedented precision it can
detect
underground mineral resources monitor
changes in water resources
and measure the rate of glacier melting
a future generation network of earth
orbiting satellites could measure
changes in the earth's gravity
so small that they could register in
real time the changes in rocks deep
underground
that might signal an imminent earthquake
or volcano
just as einstein's fundamental studies
of atoms led eventually
to the laser and all its applications
from dvd players to medicine
so also my einstein's theory of
gravitational waves
inspire new measurement systems with an
unimagined range of applications
with lisa we want to put three detectors
into a triangular array each pair of
arms is an independent detector
like one of the detectors on the ground
but these detectors overlap
so we can't easily tell the direction to
a gravitational wave source in the same
way as we did in our demonstration and
with the ground-based detectors
instead lisa will use the doppler effect
in other words from the changes in pitch
as the sound
of the gravitational wave sounds as lisa
circles the sun
watch this animation let your ears tell
you just when the train
passes the crossing
so you hear the crossing bell change
just
as you pass it lisa will locate its
sounds
in the same way through the changes in
their pitch as it circles around the sun
so our gravitational wave detectors use
the same old tricks
that our ears have always used in order
to listen
and locate sounds the tricks may be old
but gravitational waves are new nobody's
detected one yet
what we know about them comes from how
einstein changed newton's theories
about gravity it was isaac newton of
course
who showed in the 17th century that
gravity was the reason
that the planet stayed in their orbits
around the sun today we understand that
gravity
governs the development of the entire
universe
einstein recognized that gravity is in
fact the curvature of space
or more precisely space time space is no
longer just the arena in which things
happen it's an active participant
and einstein asked himself what happens
when stars circle each other
how does gravity change when the stars
move
and do these changes affect other bodies
around them
einstein of course already knew that
nothing can move faster than light
therefore he concluded
that changes in gravity had to move
through space at the speed of light
taking the form of waves any any theory
of gravity
has to have waves einstein's
gravitational waves are ripples in the
curvature of space
space of course is everywhere that means
gravitational waves
go everywhere they can't be shut out
screened away
blocked they are there for the best
messengers that we have from the dark
and hidden universe
every acceleration produces
gravitational waves
we can however only catch the strongest
of these waves
the ones that are emitted by the fastest
and most massive objects
in the universe from black holes neutron
stars
exploding stars in the big bang itself
and these waves typically can only just
be detected
because their sources are so far away
and the waves are very weak by the time
they reach us
so now we're going to do our second
demonstration and this time we're going
to use this rope
and claudia and leon leon are going to
position themselves we hope we can we
can show you um
uh exactly why um so
let's try to get more if you can stand
back here
yeah and then the first part the first
part is
about there yeah that's right we'll do
it with half the length now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to show you
why newton didn't come up with the idea
of gravitational waves but einstein did
and um uh so what i want you to imagine
is that this rope is gravity
or its space which is going to carry way
carry gravity and carry waves of gravity
so we're going to look at the waves that
are on this rope
um and
claudia is the source of the
gravitational wave she's uh being a
black hole binary again
um and this time leon is the detector
so the waves are going to come from her
and go to him
so when she pulls on her
on the rope that's like the
gravitational attraction
uh that one object exerts on another
and then she's going to change the
gravity so as she moves the rope up and
down you can imagine gravity getting a
bit stronger or getting a bit weaker as
the source as the two stars are moving
around and sometimes they're a bit
closer to you and sometimes a bit
further away and so on so
um the the changes in gravity are being
represented by
the change in the position
of the rope so
let's do the first experiment so they're
not very far apart
and when the black hole orbits
that'll make gravity stronger and weaker
and uh let's see what happens
yeah so what happens is that do it again
that's right what happens is pretty much
instantaneously
uh the the when when
claudia changes gravity over here
uh leon feels it uh you you don't see a
wave running along here the rope is just
stiff and it's just
happening okay now what
we're going to do is now i'm going to
ask claudia to go twice as far away
as far as you can get in the room that's
it that's good
and we've rehearsed this but it's very
diff
it's very difficult to do i i what we're
trying to do is move the rope in exactly
the same way and keep the tension in the
rope exactly the same
but just because the rope is longer um
uh see if you can see that there's a
some somewhat of a delay
in the um uh in in
in the reaction at this end when the
gravity changes at that end
yeah so i think you could see a wave
travel down the rope
and that means that uh because the rope
is
just because the rope is longer you're
seeing that wave when the rope was
shorter
we were less than a wavelength uh uh
of rope in front of us and and the rope
was pretty much moving
as a unit but now try it again
do do the same thing again now there's a
somewhat of a wave motion going along
there
because we're we've got more rope to
play with and so
the further away the the longer the
delay and and when it gets to be
uh comparable to uh when the when the
travel time is comparable to the time
of lifting the rope and so on um then
the wave effect becomes visible now
that's a rope it has a very slow wave
speed
gravity of course has very high waves
speed gravitational waves travel the
speed of light that's the fastest you
can go
so now we're going to try to duplicate
we're going to try to simulate that or
at least
make something that looks like that by
changing the tension in the rope we're
going to pull on the rope
as hard as we can so now we have a very
tense rope and
therefore a higher speed along
the way and cloudy is again going to be
her black hole binary
and again try to change the same thing
change it with the same motion as she
did before
and you see it vibrate but you i don't i
don't see a way of going along there i
see it happening
pretty much the same everywhere okay
this is a very simple demonstration
thank you very much
thank you for both of your
demonstrations
this is a very simple demonstration of
course but of a profound principle
about waves which is that uh
wave motion wave effects are only
visible in what
in what we call the far zone and not in
the near zone they're only visible
if you're far enough away for the waves
let's say if you're a wavelength
uh away and that depends on the speed of
the waves and it depends
upon how fast gravity is changing for
example so if things are changing
slowly then the wavelength is very long
and you have to be very far away to
appreciate it
and so now if i go back to
the discussion being einstein and newton
um remember that einstein changed
newton's theory
to put in the delay but only a delay
that travels with the speed of light
which is very very fast
and so um newton he wanted to explain
the solar system he built
the first reflecting telescope he made
observations of the planets himself
and he discovered the law of gravity
that would explain the motions of the
planets but the planets move very slowly
in their orbits compared to the speed of
light so gravitational waves that they
produce
have very very long wavelengths light
years
the wavelength is much much bigger than
the solar system
so the experiment we just we just did
shows
that gravity in the solar system isn't
affected by gravitational waves there's
no evidence of gravitational waves in
our solar system
and it's not surprising that newton
didn't incorporate them
into his theory his theory didn't need
them he didn't include them
but today we know about cosmic objects
that move
very very fast for example black holes
and neutron stars in orbits close
close to one another can be going at
speeds a good fraction of the speed of
light
so we need a theory that has gray that
has waves
and that's what einstein general theory
of relativity
gives us remarkably the french physicist
laplace
speculated about gravitational waves
around the year 1800
he believed gravity had to have a finite
speed and he understood that this would
lead to waves
but it took another century before
einstein could make a full theory of
gravity
that had the waves and quantitatively
was correct
this film shows what they are like
gravitational waves stretch and squeeze
space as they fly through the universe
they change the distances between points
in space
our laser interferometers measure the
tiny changes in length that they create
gravitational waves affect all objects
because they affect space itself
a given gravitational wave always
produces the same change in shape
no matter how big or small the system
therefore we build the biggest possible
detectors so that the stretching is as
large as possible
even so it's a huge technological and
scientific challenge
to detect these gravitational waves even
the biggest stretching
remains very small and measuring it
is is tough so we want to listen to the
universe
we aren't there yet but step by step
we're improving the sensitivity of our
detectors and our microphones for these
gravitational waves
within just one or two years we may well
begin to listen
to these wild animals of outer space
and when lisa is launched we will get
the strangest and the loudest
gravitational wave sounds ever
with lisa we will listen to the
collisions and merging of
giant black holes and we also create
events
in these events in our super computers
by solving einstein's equations
and we'll learn a lot from these
simulations
exotic as they seem black hole binaries
are among the simplest and cleanest
systems in nature from their
gravitational waves we can read off the
masses of the holes
how strong the waves are that they are
emitted and
even exactly how far the system is away
from us
solving einstein's equations on a
supercomputer as here
shows us what these events look like in
their final orbits in the final moment
of merging
two black holes are emitting energy
faster than everything else
in the entire universe put together
light energy
x-rays everything is less energy in
luminosity than that black hole
binary now here we see a giant black
hole with a smaller black hole
in orbit around it with lisa we'll
listen to the dying moments of this
smaller black hole as it's being eaten
by the giant one
because this kind of merger takes much
much longer than
than than it does when the holes are the
same size we get a much more
a much richer amount of information and
we can use it to test einstein's theory
what we're hearing is that a year of
expected lisa
data compressed to a minute in order to
raise the pitch of the signal
into the audible range this music of the
spheres
it's not very musical but its complexity
contains all that information about the
orbit and about the central black hole
and the most important part was that
it stopped that's the proof
that the central object was a black hole
that's the proof
that the orbiting object fell inside and
disappeared
the silence that follows is the best
proof that we have
that black holes really exist
lisa will actually hear much more than
this
the data that we're listening to here if
we can hear
it um it's a bit low
uh i apologize for that but this is
this is the whole sound of the entire
galaxy
it includes mergers of distant black
holes but also binary systems in our own
galaxy
now this is what we expect to hear when
eventually we can listen to the very
beginning of the universe
the big bang
listening to this hiss is the ultimate
prize a gravitational wave astronomy
are you disappointed did you expect a
large bang from the big bang
remember this is 14 billion years ago
the source is 14 billion light years
away it's a
very quiet persistent hiss of
gravitational waves reaching us
but it's the ultimate prize it's what we
all want to detect
these are radio waves from the big bang
the the my cosmic microwave background
we want to be able to detect the
gravitational
waves also in the cosmic microwave
background which are the radio waves
coming out of the big bang and bicep too
claimed to have detected these last year
but the european planck satellite
showed that what they had been misled by
was foreground uh effects in the
polarization of the
of the microwaves so that the
polarization wasn't
that was what would have been induced by
gravitational waves
but in a another year or two we may well
be able to
detect the gravitational waves in the
big bang itself
from the polarization now the beginning
of gravitational wave astronomy will be
a breakthrough that gives us a tool with
which we'll be able to observe hidden
regions and as yet
unknown monsters in our jungle as in
other areas astronomy we get the best
results
when we bring together other ways of
observing as well
for instance uh gamma ray satellites
that will work with ligo and virgo to
tell us what causes
the bursts of gamma rays that they
constantly detecting
we call this multi-messenger astronomy
in the next decade astronomers will be
using their newest and most powerful
telescopes as we saw the extremely large
telescope
and the square kilometer array of radio
telescopes about to be built
they'll follow up gravitational wave
events study their environments learn
how they formed
and find out what effects they've had on
their surroundings
how how black holes for example shaped
our own galaxy
what else will we learn from these
technologies as we put them together
and and match them up with telescopes to
reveal the hidden and dark side
of our universe
when we use our gravitational waves to
listen we hear the dynamic universe and
the universe is dynamic
it's a restless universe nothing stands
still nothing is at rest
the universe is filled with things in
motion all of it radiating gravitational
waves
so
foreign
thank you very much
you